*LWIAY intro song*
*record scratch*
*intense music start plays*
No more fun and games.
No more sitting on our asses.
No more handing out posters.
Tonight we FIGHT!
Tonight we kill T-SERIES!!!!
We MURDER T-Series.
But why is it taking you so goddamn long?
*impovised fighting noises*
p-p-p-p-puh!
You suck, T-Series!
This whole "T-Series suck" meme is getting kinda old!
p-p-puah!
ha!
Wait! What was that?
Did you guys see that??
What was that?
What the frick?!
Hello and welcome everyone to LWIAY.
*slowly sinking into a T-Series trap*
Let's just *clap* jump *clap*  into it.
Yesterday,
last night, before I went to sleep,
the absolute mad lad,
Elon Musk
posted with a...
is that a gatling gun? What is that? (laughs)
Is that a nine year old in the back?!
*amused confusion*
You see what I'm talking about?
We are not handing out posters anymore.
We are going at war.
We have Elon Musk at our side.
*gunshots in the background* (laughter)
I love how he replied to MrBeast as well
I triple dog dare you to host meme review.
Five bucks.
I'll give you five bucks and I'll buy a Tesla.
You drive a hard bargain, but ok.
*chuckling*
Tesla is now the official car of the meme community.
Why did you buy a Tesla?
Oh, you know, as a meme. Just as a meme.
Petition for Jablinski to say "Subscribe to
Pedwiepie" at the Oscars ceremony
*chuckling*
Where's the petition?
Where is it, goddammit?
Jack Black, the possibility of him saying
"subscrie to pewdiepie" at the oscars
*chuckling*
Pewds not realizing he's wearing headphones...
wait, what?
What is she playing? Is she playing bitch lasagna?
You are wearing headphones, Felix.
Being closer to the...
*chuckling*
*laughing*
Being closer **still dying of laughter**
to the computer does nothing...
*inaudible laughter*
Hey, listen here!
How DARE YOU
question my intelligence!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
You don't know how headphones... (inaudible)
These are... distance oriented headphones.
New prototype from Razer.
We're working on it.
We got the top people at the top working on this
to stay high-end technology.
And you DARE ridicule me for being an actual brainlet?
For being actually Sub-Zero IQ?
Is that what you doing?
Didn't think so.
Oh, look, it's more people pointing out that I'm an idiot.
or...
What's it gonna be now? Can't wait.
Has own headphone design with integrated mic
clips on external mic... *chuckle*
*inaudible laughter*
Hey, that's smart, ok?
Has a TV
doesn't watch the TV.
It takes effort to put a picture up there!
Has his own merch, wears plain white t-shirt.
Well, sometimes it's nice to be simple, okay?
Has his own chair design, stands
Well, I like standing! Okay?
Has his own sponsored energy drink, drinks RedBull
I don't drink RedBull, I was drinking...
flavored sparkling water.
Checkmate!
Girl: *disrespectful to her parents*
Dr. Phil: ranch!
What if I...
go on Dr. Phil and he examines me
and he sends ME to the ranch
I could... ranch vlogs!
Smash like if you're excited for ranch vlogs!
How it really is... *laughing*
*Clap*
Just as I remembered it.
Mark actually carries a stool with him anywhere he goes, so anytime you se him in any shot
this is what it actually looks like.
I'm going to link all the creators I just mentioned
Now... they could be nazis, I haven't checked pls
I like how that's an actual disclaimer
I have to put now, unironically
I'm not supposed to share my opinion, BUT
Name *clap* a more *clap* iconic *clap* duo! *clap*
You can't! You can't.
Doc, I feel like I'm becoming a normie.
What do you do when you see a funny meme?
I smile and scroll by
Patient *whispers* is ready for the ranch */w*
*Whispering* Ranch!
*Still whispering* Ranch!
*Whispering* Ready for the ranch!
Send him to the ranch
O h  m y  G o d
oh, my God
What is happening? *uncomfortable sniff*
What the hell?
Dr Phil: Kinda get back hostile defensive reactions.
If you put out a message that says
Pewds: What is this?!
Dr Phil: I want to engage
I wanna be involved
I want to--
I made my computer run 16 hours
To get Pewdiepie's face
on Dr. Phil
This is the result.
Dr. Phil: ... support me and that are
engaged with what I do in my life
Holy s 🅱 🅱 🅱!
Dr. Phil: You're gonna get people that come and engage in your life
Pewds: OOoH MY GOD
Dr. Phil: and they want you to be involved in theirs.
That's amazing.
Bitch Lasagna on 20 different instruments.
Tried getting this on LWIAY, but still didn't get featured.
Okay, well I'm watching it now so this best be good.
There we go
🎵ukulele🎵
🎵keyboard🎵
What an audience. Wow, what a terrific audience.
🎵acoustic guitar🎵
Sound good!
🎵violin🎵
Oh, is that livestreamed? *chuckles*
🎵an actual bitch🎵
🎵female dog🎵
Oh!
🎵bitch🎵
On an actual-- *laughs*
🎵marker🎵
Oho!
Okay *chortles*
🎵marker🎵
🎵rock guitar🎵
Wow, with a rock guitar. Really feel it.
🎵tiny piano🎵
*chuckles*
Is that in Spain? That can't...
🎵tiny piano🎵
🎵grand piano🎵
Okay, very nice.
🎵kazoo🎵
Oh!
🎵cigar box guitar🎵
Cigar box guitar?
🎵acoustic bass🎵
What the hell is that?
It's got a good sound to it.
🎵acoustic bass🎵
🎵cajon🎵
🎵glasses🎵
Of course.
🎵jew's harp🎵
Is that what it's called?
🎵Beatsaber🎵
I don't know, I-feel-like-- EEYY! *laughs*
*laughs*
🎵Beatsaber🎵
Oh damn, he's actually good at it
🎵lasagna🎵
*heaves while gripping sides*
OH!
🎵banjolele🎵
🎵melodica🎵
All at the same time-- no
🎵mayonnaise🎵
Eeww!
*laughs*
🎵mayonnaise🎵
Now THAT'S an instrument.
🎵nyahh!🎵
That's what it-- oh
pt-t-t-t-t-t-bah *splashing*
Oh my God
Pt-t *splash*
*grunts like papa franku*
Okay
*clap* Felix *clap* S *clap* R
*clap* VERY *clap* EPIC *clap* THANK YOU
*Continues clapping* FelixSR, you did it.
That's incredible.
The mayonnaise was definitely my favorite.
Petition for Pewds to make a leg reveal at 100 million
That's what I'm saying.
After all these years
Leg *clap* Reveal *clap*
These World War 2 bunkers are just incredible
*dead inside*
Wow, that's fascinating.
Wow.
The rea- wait what?
The real reason why the sub gap rose
I called an ENTIRE phone book for Pewdipie
Oh my God, it's real.
Hello, my name's Isaiah
I'm calling on behalf of Felix Kjellberg
Calling on behalf of Pewdiepie.
Hi my name's Isaiah
I'm calling on behalf of Pewdipie
Felix Kjellberg Foundation
If you can go on there and
and subscribe to his channel for me
I think you've got the wrong number.
No, I don't think so. (Poor woman)
I don't
I don't have any cutie pie.
*Pewds goes aww*
Well, I'll tell you what. I'll have...
I'll have
I'll have my uhh
My associate
follow up with you in a few days here
Her name's Gloria Borger
she'll give you a call.
Woman of phone: "I don't know her either."
What?
Well that's why you need to subscribe god dammit. :(
Isaiah Photo, that's great.
Thank you very much for doing you part.
Incredible.
Incredible job.
*Pewds laughing at cat meme*
Brad #1 when he's editing PewDiePie's video's and he has to add the code *earrape not cool brad*
Could we get Pewds to see that his own game hasn't updated his subcount.
*clap* NANI?
This game is IRELLEVANT!
This game is GARBAGE! How DARE YOU!
*laughter*
Pills that make you stare at
certain Swedish man who never asks his subreddit any actual questions.
*chuckle*
Hey don't look at me like that okay!?
You guys did this. I had nothing to partake in it
I used to ask you questions and all you guys posted were memes.
So I thought, hey, i'll just roll with it anyway then.
They don't want.
They don't want to ask questions.
They just want shitposts.
And it ain't my fault and you can blame it on me as much as you like.
Petition for Pewds to name Dr. Phil episodes:
"child rewiew" *clap*
*clap*
Well they all get zero's so it would'nt be that interesting, but.
Oh god it was Brad all along.
Only he can harness Shaggy's true power.
*intense music starts playing*
Oh my god.
The power of Shaggy.
*intense music is still playing*
How could we have been so blind.
Brad is Shaggy form Scooby Doo.
SCOOBY DOOBY DOO!
This makes me so exited.
*flat out silence*
How tall is Adolf Hitler?
[I agree]
Just hit 67 million subs! Probably my last milestone to be first at reaching.
That was a ****ing lie
A beautiful lie.
ᴬ ᵇᵉᵃᵘᵗᶦᶠᵘˡ ˡᶦᵉ.
Petition to get Alinity on Dr. Phil so she can be sent to the ranch.
*claps of agreement*
Please God, please.
I will never ask you for anything else.
Just... ehh. *wheeze*
Petition for Pewds to play Wii Sports
You guys are spying on my setup.
AH.
*laughs at a family guy meme*
I actually laughed at a Family Guy meme.
Unironically.
Congratulations to me. I did it
Making a normal meme.
Adding myself on the background so i can get myself in to LWIAY
WHAT! No, no.
The reason that the Shaggy meme hasn't died yet is because he's gotten too,
he's to powerful to be forgotten.
God Damn.
Brad, what have you done?!
How could you do this
Damn
This came out of nowhere.
Oh! *Pewds getting exited*
What?
*chuckle*
[Don't know what sound he was going for here]
*laughter*
Eyy!
Oh!
*chuckle*
*chuckles*
whoow
Damn.
Back at it again.
Alright, if you guys haven't subbed to Sage yet.
[watch out, could be a Nazi]
Do it right now!
Incredible channel, obviously he's fire.
Made fanart of Brad so the chances of this getting into LWIAY has increased substantially.
WHAT!
*Wheeze/No*
Built PewDiePie in Minecraft.
How is that even possible?
Timelapse here.
SirArzey.
Wow.
Holy!
Oh okay.
That's crazy.
Damn.
I think YouTube did an oopsie.
Oh, we were on trending, I didn't even realise.
That must've been an oopsie. I guess YouTube realised.
PewDiePie
The N word.
Brad editing.
That's not true. 2X
Oh my god, how tall is Felix?
A Scientific Study
Diameter of PewDiePies headset is 11,2 cm.
By measuring the headset, we are able to calculate the size of Felix's head.
My head is 27 centimeters.
Calculated by using proportion of headset to rest of his head
Once we have the size of the head,
we can calculate his overall height.
Calculated by using proportion of head to rest of the body.
Felix's height:
it equals roughly 177,5 centimeters.
Oh god.
But wait. Everybody knows that Felix doesn't actually have any legs.
HIS ACTUAL HEIGHT.
AH!
*INAUDIBLE GRUNT*
*ANOTHER INAUDIBLE GRUNT*
*rip headphones* :(
This is lies.
This is a conspiracy he posted from Vox.
Don't believe it.
I want you to get up of your ass, and subscribe to PewDiePie.
Next,
*soft clap*
meme.
You heard *clap* it here *clap* first.
Subscribe to PewDiePie.
We have grandma's on our side.
Grandma's!
*prehistoric grunt*
Alright, smash like.
Smash like subscribe on this video.
Thank you guys for watching. Thanks for all the memes.
I love recording these video's.
I am so proud of this community.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
What's it gonna be? Double LWIAY?
DOUBLE LWIAY?
Two LWIAY'S in a row.
That would be ****ing crazy.
You want Pyramid's?
We got em!
Oh, you into castles huh?
We got you covered baby!
You want some pets?!
Easy!
We got it all!
*Eagle soundeffect #3*
This game is still relevant god dammit!
*theme song of PewDiePie's Tuber Simulator.